c'est interminable cette manifestation
ottawa je pense que quelqu'un qui vit à
ottawa aurait des mots beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus pour la décrire parce
qu'elle est klaxon mais il ya aussi
maintenant de plus en plus de
témoignages de gens qui se font harceler
qu'ils sont intimidés on évoque même une
tentative de mettre le feu dans un
building où les gens se plaignaient des
manifestants et du bruit entre autres
choses la manifestation elle a été
déclarée légal hier par le maire mais on
a l'impression que la police est
incapable de disperser les manifestants
malgré les outils qu'on lui a donné
hélène qu'est-ce que vous en pensez les
policiers ont demandé à l'aide
aujourd'hui disent écoutez on a eu des
renforts ans et pas assez on a besoin de
mille huit cents policiers de plus
encore oui ce qui équivaudrait quasiment
afin de doubler les effectifs de la
police d'ottawa qui a déjà reçu à peu
près de 275 policiers de la grc en plus
vous avez raison en fait la difficulté
c'est que au manque d'équipement
notamment ceux le le chef de police a
reconnu que l'obstacle principal pour
l'heure pour dissiper cette
manifestation c'est le fait qu'on n'a
pas de capacité de remorquage suffisante
ça prend des équipements spéciaux pour
aller chercher des 18 roule on remarque
pas ça avec la cia et on manque
d'effectifs et une énorme principal
obstacle aujourd'hui un tribunal au rang
d'une injonction pour dire qu'on ne peut
pas que l'actionnaire les gens présenté
cela comme une victoire mais moi je suis
pas certain de quelle différence afro
parce qu' il existe déjà des règlements
municipaux contre le bruit excessif et
c'est surtout encore une fois la
capacité de faire appliquer ses
règlements le qui manquent alors c'est
de la force et du jus de broc il faut en
ce moment parce qu'en réalité mais c'est
ça parce que ce que vous êtes c'est
l'heure maintenant il au juge qui
s'emmêlent mail et déjà déclaré illégale
cette manifestation michel en fait
demandé des renforts c'est quand son
doublé les services de police ont
pourtant tout le monde dit non non ça
relève du minispace et à la ville de
gérer c'est sur son territoire c'est ce
qui est un peu incroyable de vue d'une
conférence de presse de plusieurs
milliers sont aujourd'hui j'aime bien ce
truc fédéraux qu'ils allaient devez nous
on au programme avec ça on peut aider la
coordination non le gouvernement fédéral
la raison pour laquelle les manifs et là
c'est que le gouvernement fédéral 6h à
avoir c'est pas juste une question de
poids les locales de ne pas d'autre part
il ya des problèmes techniques
absolument impossible à régler la et 18
roucas amassé 18 ferait une logique sur
les routes ça bouge qu à l'arrière même
la meilleure de
chercher alors il va falloir négocier
avec ces gens là même si c'est ce qu'ils
font n'est pas considéré comme le com
légal il va enfin il va falloir leur
parler parce que sinon cette affaire le
plus dur en contre et longtemps mais le
gouvernement ne peut pas ça ça laver les
mains comme il le fait aujourd'hui c'est
honteux
et on a vu au début ça c'est un peu ma
me rené comes the hat cette
manifestation le finalement l emporter
avec elle l'ex chef du parti
conservateur
monsieur autour mais la halle et qu'on
se demande jusqu'à quel point ça va pas
durement aussi touchés justin trudeau on
a l'impression aujourd'hui qu'il
commence à être rattrapé en fait ce que
tout le monde dénonce ces son absence il
est invisible depuis jeudi dernier
c'est certain qu'il ait dû pour
communiquer avec la population
communiqué ou parler avec les
manifestants soit je suis pas certain à
partir du moment où lors de leur demande
soit complètement loufoque est
impossible est possible
à mettre en application la levée des
mesures sanitaires d'avoir sa peau de
tahoua salem des provinces qui ont les
etats-unis aussi demande la vaccination
des camionneurs qui traversent la
frontière donc on va décider la place de
washington donc transporté manière grand
chose à négocier avec eux ces personnes
là moi je me demande pas donc oui
trudeau doit être plus présent peut-être
passer un message moi ce que je me pose
comme question c'est où est le
gouvernement ford en fait dans cette
crise là oui le gouvernement fédéral
siège à ottawa mais si le gouvernement
fort qui devrait venir en aide à sa
ville c'est comme si si montréal était
paralysée et le gouvernement de françois
legault faisait rien on se demanderait
ou et la sûreté du québec et hockey oui
la police provinciale ontarienne est le
devenir un peu un coup de main mais elle
est capable de faire beaucoup plus il ya
beaucoup plus de ressources du côté du
gouvernement de queen's park pour aider
la ville de tahoua qu'est-ce qu'ils font
jusqu'à présent oui eu quelques
gazouillis le dr le s'il vous plaît
donnez l'impression à l'est qui fait
tout pour s'éloigner de ce sujet là lui
le il bascule en élections il veut pas
se retrouver finalement avec le poids de
la crise sur les épaules c'est vrai mais
il sait sa province le sait ottawa le
sais c'est pas pour détacher notariaux
le ca reste une ville quitte à
l'intérieur de l'autre de l'ontario
après le premier rempart que la police
municipale qui clame a débordé pour
cogner à la porte de toronto où faute
qu'on ait de l'aide du côté de la police
provinciale oui la grc d'un coup de main
mais c'est faux que d'hommes forts aussi
soit partie prenante de cette de 7 200
réponses à sa crise l'heure de la crise
sont là en plus ma peau du moins là
dessus et oui j'allais dire allez que
tout à fait raison je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup que pourrait faire le
gouvernement provincial qui n'est pas
fait notamment et c'était une suggestion
faite aujourd'hui par les ministres
fédéraux déployées c'est à dire de de
suspendre les licences de ses compagnies
de transport qui relève de souvent du
provincial on a les numéros
d'immatriculation on peut retracer les
propriétaires des centres ces
entreprises là on peut leur faire très
mal dire aux entreprises gardes tu
pourras plus granit akrout ici tu
n'enlève pas ton camion il ya des moyens
de pression qui peuvent être exercés
mais clairement oui l'élection doit
jouer quelque chose dans la balance les
conservateurs sont en général divisés
sur cette question puis on va en
reparler j'imagine les pros et les
contres du convoi et peut-être que
monsieur x 2 essaye de ne pas trop
perdre de capital politique montre que
ce qu'il en reste à la vue en prévision
de cette élection printanière mais
plonge hors jeu sous mandant les
conservateurs et leur position là dessus
parce que ce qu'au début ce qu'on a vu
avant même de la manifestation commence
c'était des messages depuis pierre
poilievre d'ailleurs était de ceux là
c'est le même temps qu'il a à la cheffe
suppléante candice bergen était cela
elle aussi là on a vu monsieur paul hus
qui lui a dénoncé les manifestations
ensemble c'est un goût partie il y avait
des noms très peu élogieux pour décrire
les manifestants reste qu'aujourd'hui on
les a entendus à tahoua dire mais les
faux que le premier ministre s'en mêle
mais il faut qu'il lève cette obligation
vaccinale alors ils disent oui ils
doivent partir mais le gouvernement doit
céder c'est ce qu'ils disent finalement
michel
oui et de toute façon pour tous les
policiers c'est une patate chaude qui
veulent pas toucher ses gonds c'est vrai
monsieur trudeau c'est vrai pour le
parti conservateur c'est vrai le
gouvernement de l'intérieur alors sont
qu'à un moment donné il faut qu'il y ait
de chip quelque part est quelqu'un qui
l'exercent et c'est certainement paul
partie de policiers officiel qui est en
train d'exercer parce que jusqu'à un
certain point vous l'avez dit plusieurs
des têtes d affiche de ce parti là sont
plutôt d'accord avec la manifestation
vise de toute façon ça nous fera pas de
temps parce que
quelque part si c'est rideau qui les
gouvernent de ma vie mais je ne sais pas
si ça pose
mes cheveux je pense que la politique
c'est juste d'embarrasser l'autre je
pensais tout petit peu plus compliqué
que ça donne une mauvaise image à toute
la classe politique et qu
on avait une sortie aujourd'hui du chef
du npd jack médecine qui est arrivé avec
un autre type de message lee ils
demandent un débat d'urgence aujourd'hui
il s'inquiète surtout c'est le volet
ingérence possible étrangère des dons
qui proviennent des états unis on va
l'écouter là dessus
deuxièmement c'est clair qu'il y a de
l'interférence étrangers
particulièrement des états unis et on
doit arrêter ça tout de suite c'est
clair que les organisateurs 17 ce convoi
ce n'est pas une manifestation et veut
werner remplacé le gouvernement qui
était élu dans un manière démocratique
il veut compenser ça avec que métiers
des gens pas élu donc c'est complètement
c'est clermont et et d'indifférence
étrangères et n'est pas le seul à
aborder ce volet l'homme a reconnu que
l'ancien gouverneur de la banque du
canada et de la banque d'angleterre
aussi lui même actuellement résidente
d'ottawa va exactement dans le même sens
en disant gouvernement vous devez agir
il ya une ingérence étrangère ici et il
terminait sa lettre ouverte avec ses
mots il dit je sais par expérience que
les crises ne se termine pas d'elle-même
dont c'est clairement un appel au
gouvernement de faire quelque chose
faire quoi sur ce volet non avec
d'abord les parlementaires ont demandé
un comité de recevoir les dirigeants de
go famille pour savoir un peu comment
fonctionne leur plate forme d'où est
venu l'argent est ce que l'argent va
être distribué depuis go for me et didon
va votre tribu l'argent on va rembourser
les donateurs on ne l'est pas on va pas
prendre l'argent qu'il a donnée à
différents groupes perçue est
intéressant de les entendre quand même
pour savoir en plus ils ont la
provenance géographique de ces dons
lolli mais des millions de dollars qui
ont été versés parce qu'à voir
l'étonnant
républicains aux états unis que son hôte
exo soit en fleuret dire à quel point
c'est donc grave dégoût famille ne
distribue pas l'argent ça montre à quel
point il avait beaucoup de donateurs
américains républicains et en timide
hausse et même 30 part dénoncé jean et
louis donc il ya clairement de l'argent
le qui viennent de l'étranger à quel
point c'est difficile à établir
peut-être qu'avec un témoignage le comme
les propriétaires les les présidents de
vos familles on pourra la voir un peu
plus d'informations mais qu'un comité
parlementaire se penche là tu me semble
la moindre des choses parce que même le
chef de police d'ottawa a dit c'est
clair qu'il ya dedans cette
organisation-là d'argent qui venaient de
l'étranger des organisateurs qui
viennent de l'étranger donc en chef de
police dit oui on a les preuves à cet
effet l'eau il ya quelque chose
d'inquiétant michel vous avez chapeau
aussi d'analysé politique américaine ya
bien des observateurs disent ils qu'ils
regardent sopi qui disent mais il se
mêle de quoi les américains qu'est ce
qu'ils font en fait
la droite américaine est la droite
religieuse américaine en particulier a
toujours eu des liens avec le canada
obtient toujours eu des des atomes
crochus avec l'organisation alors ça
c'est pas nouveau ce qui est nouveau
c'est le sociaux financement le goff
ovni mais les rythmes se trompent pas
tweeté aujourd'hui en disant
cette rue d'auch est en train de se
faire avoir par ces camionneurs c'est
une bonne chose bon il ya toujours
détesté justin trudeau mais
effectivement il ya quelque chose de
quasiment romantique pour la droite
américaine de
ski mont est la colline parlementaire ça
c'est une bonne chose à condition que ça
se passera chez eux évidemment mais
c'est dans les 3 millions dé plus de
personnes qui ont regardé la vidéo de
monsieur premier jeu très très surpris
de savoir convié américaine je pense qu
à ne plus créative et quand on voit ce
que certains médias dont fox font
avec ceci étant si vous parlez poilievre
parce qu'on est dans un esprit justement
de course à la direction du parti
conservateur elle a été regardée mais
des millions de fois cette vidéo si dont
lé spectateur ne l'avait pas vu voici le
petit exploit
est-ce qu'on joue l'extrait on va y
aller
utilisons le coc vie comme opportunité
politique le gouvernement trudeau
attaquent nos petites entreprises
camionneurs et travailleurs trous d'eau
pense qu'il est votre patron qui se
trompe c'est le contraire vous êtes le
patron
et je serai candidat pour devenir
premier ministre afin de vous redonner
le contrôle de votre vie
bon bah y'a comme sauter une étape
hélène se présente comme suit parti
conservateur mais carrément
pierre poilievre côté de la barre
d'abord plusieurs le présente comme une
rock-star au sein du parti conservateur
c'est un député qui malgré ses 42 ans
est un vieux routier de la politique
parce qu'étant rentrée il avait à peine
25 ans il ne fait que ça dans sa vie de
la politique c'est un politicien
extrêmement abrasifs on pourrait dire
même teigneux hargneux qui ont un sens
extraordinaire de la formule c'est
souvent celui qui attaque à la chambre
des communes mais justement se passer de
chiens d'ataxie je peux dire est ce
vraiment ce qui va peut-être le plus
nuire à sa capacité de croissance alors
en ce moment les conservateurs qui sont
déjà dans le parti voit en lui comme le
candidat idéal parce qu'il véhicule et
cette colère est aussi dans la vidéo
révélée thèmes traditionnels non à la
censure d'internet il parlait des médias
contrôlés par les gouvernements donc
cette thématique un peu populiste qu'on
pourrait attribuer même un peu à tromper
alors il est totalement là dessus mais
est ce qu'il va être capable d'élargir
est là et tout le défi du parti
conservateur moi j'en suis vraiment pas
certaine de ça et c'est une personne qui
peut être très cassantes et rebutante
pour ceux qui n'adhèrent pas déjà sa
candidature ils risquent de polariser
beaucoup cette course au leadership
manifestement il ya des craintes du côté
de certains membres du caucus québécois
du caucus conservateur alain reyes et un
seul d'abord il a quitté ses fonctions
de lieutenant politique pour le québec
il dit maintenant qu'il veut unifier le
parti conservateur mais surtout défendre
le côté progressiste centre droit en
soulignant le mont centre ici il n'est
pas le seul monsieur paul le souci mais
les deux ont évoqué le nom de jean
charest comme un candidat intéressant à
la chefferie on les écoute
j'apporte à la politique canadienne
venir à la course risque soit un
candidat exceptionnel pour faire des
débats est très intéressant l'ancien
premier ministre s'y était chef partie
au fédéral il connaît la joute c'est une
machine politique clairement il maîtrise
parfaitement les deux langues
officielles comme tout le monde ici qui
connaît le québec parfaitement puis le
canada
dont ils ont l'air d'être en campagne de
séduction pour essayer de convaincre
jean charest est ce qu'il peut se
laisser convaincre l'alec
ce qui peut se laisser convaincre il ya
des différences un peu par rapport à il
ya deux ans lorsqu'il avait décidé de ne
pas plonger chercherait
d'abord le caucus du québec est
désespérée la dernière fois il ne
l'était pas il y avait peut-être mais
qui étaient là qui représentait les
autorise le plus progressiste
conservatrice il a perdu il est donc
attaché à une défaite des si loin d'être
certain que le goût de se présenter donc
les députés du québec et même des
maritimes se cherche désespérément un
poulain pour faire face à pierre
poilievre qu'ils ne voient pas comme
étant du tout de centre-droit et donc
certainement encore plus d'appels du
pied que la dernière fois pour jean
charest donc lorsqu'on essaie de faire
c'est de monter une équipe pour jean
charest hors du québec parce que
maintenant qui aurait l'appui suffisant
probablement au québec c'est qui peut
pas gagner seulement avec le québec et
les maritimes ça ils prendraient de
l'accusé puis dans l'ouest donc c'est ce
qu'il est en train de tester pour voir
si ça va lui tenter ou non y voyez moi
je pense qu'il va y avoir une course de
toute façon parce que pierre poilievre
ne sera pas couronné d'avoir les plis
pro vie les anti avortement du parti
conservateur étant donné que pour
pallier votre pro choix vont
certainement assez de se trouver leur
poulain pour la remontée pour mousser
leur agenda comme il l'avait fait la
dernière fois avec leslie de noël spider
island on pense qu'on va y avoir
quelqu'un tasha kheiriddin d'un
chroniqueur qu'on a déjà eu comme
analyste réfléchit sérieusement
je savais qu'on aille en honda et elle
commence à parler un peu de sa vision le
rôle qu'elle pourrait jouer pour unifier
les parties dont clairement l'essai de
faire mousser son ongle je pense qu'il
est clairement favori je pense que
pierre poilievre est favori parce
qu'elles viennent par cylindre raison
c'est quelqu'un qui est très bien vu par
léman mais de là le laisser aller
à ne présenter personnes qui ont suivi
les différentes factions de la coalition
conservatrice n'avons pas si facilement
dit oui on donne le trône je pense qu'il
va y avoir une course maintenant reste à
voir qui va avoir l'audace de se lancer
en sachant que la côte quand même boîte
à remonter michel le nom de jean charest
dès qu'on évoque une réaction
automatique
dans les réseaux sociaux il ya des gens
qui disent ben voyons dont jean charest
ça pas de bon sens il ya une enquête qui
est même pas terminé à son sujet il ya
quelque chose de toxique est liée à ce
nom là et que d'une part hier ça et les
casseroles sont pas disparus depuis la
dernière fois c'est vrai que l'upac et
un peu moins à la mode est un peu moins
crédible qu'elle l'était avant mais je
les relais les casseroles la réputation
que monsieur charest a laissé quand il
quand il était chef libéral est pas
nécessairement un avantage de prix
l'après seul réseau je pense si shrek en
cantine domicile pour se présentèrent du
bel 20 il a dit ce parti-là a trop
changé depuis le temps où moi j'en étais
membre
c'est encore pire maintenant c'est il ya
eu des navires est un peu plus à droite
le parti conservateur qui est ici et
l'image sont déployés mais ça va être
encore pas mal plus alors donc les
raisons qui l'ont amené à pas se
présenter il ya il ya deux ans et demi
sont encore là et sont être plus
importante il ya 63 ans ça fait presque
dix ans qu'ils aient quitté la vie
politique sur fait une carrière dans le
monde des affaires et d'être nommé au
conseil d'administration du cns qui ont
le goût ça c'est une autre question
c'est pas la question aujourd'hui on a
tenté de l'invité non
je m'attendais pas enfin pour toujours
essayé à ce soit notre devoir hélène là
dessus en fait on se demande oui il peut
y avoir une course mais monsieur
poilievre sont tellement vite dans la
course on voit déjà les faits poilievre
une certaine façon il ya d'autres gens
ont essayé d'autres noms qui circulent
vincent guillot son service que ce
sérieux on est ravi bah écoutez il avait
déjà laissé circuler son nom à la
dernière course mais il avait fait une
sortie quand même sur le contrôle les
armes à feu en disant que c'était
important il était en rupture totale
avec le parti conservateur donc lui
aussi pourrait surprendre les militants
conservateurs à ses pulsions jean
charest pour toutes les raisons
mentionnées par mes deux collègues je
suis vraiment pas certaine qu'il se
lancerait il est temps il est évidemment
flatté par ses appels qui le reçoit
beaucoup mais les raisons de 2020 sont
encore là il ne se retrouve pas dans ce
parti on veut dit qu'il était très
frileux à se relancer et même madame
carradine peut-être d'un intérêt mais en
fait je pense que voudrait d'abord se
faire élire comme député avant de songer
à diriger le parti mais voilà c'est tout
déjà pour nous merci pour ce panel ce
soir
au revoir